au début du confinement beaucoup de
couples se sont certainement dit que
vivre 24 heures sur 24 l'un sur l'autre
serait sûrement une épreuve de taille à
surmonter
oui mais voilà une nouvelle étude
indique que s'il multiplie les
engueulades le confinement multiplient
aussi la libido en voilà une bonne
nouvelle selon cette étude réalisée par
we vibe 25% des français admettre que
cette période de confinement et de
distanciation sociale a augmenté leurs
envies de rapports sexuels une libido
booster qui permet à une personne sur
cinq en couple d'avoir plus de rapport
avec son partenaire qu'en période
normale et il n'y a pas que les amoureux
qui sont ensemble qu'ils ont envie de
s'amuser car si le confinement à séparer
temporairement plusieurs couples leur
envie d'avoir des relations intimes a
augmenté dans 73% des cartes des
français qui choisissent l'option du
plaisir solitaire en attendant de
pouvoir de nouveau serré dans les bras
l'homme où la femme de leur vie voilà
vous avez vu alors c'est une étude et je
vous donnerai la troisième infos du jour
sur le confinement vous allez voir ce
qui est très bon comment qui se traitent
vous dire l anti stress très bon en
cette période
alors est ce que vous confirmez laurence
sailly oui je crois que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour tout le monde parce que ça
fait partie des choses qui vont
peut-être après se maintenir et pour un
couple c'est une belle chose de sûr
l'amour mais vous tout seul ça
n'intéresse pas particulièrement ce sont
de vraies mais quand je rêvais mais le
préfet était tout seul
laurie qu'on embrasse merci monsieur je
sais tout ça
alors ce que je dit ça c'est que pour
bien connaître ça le sexe c'est quand tu
ne pratique plus de la plus envie c'est
comme le sucre n'est pas en chocolat
tout ça donc moi la première semaine je
pense pas que c'était un petit peu
compliqué on va dire que j'avais encore
envie de sucre mais là ça y est c'est
passé puisque de toute façon je vais pas
me taper mabrouk est je suis tout seul
donc donc la non là c'est passé c'est
passé mais là je te dis pas que quand ça
va revenir
faudra pas dedans fera pas dans le coin
quoi pourra pas tout à balai alors lui
dans le sud des bombes à retardement hui
lors le clivar lui alors lui apportera
je ne sais pas je sais pas où en est la
minuterie mais quand l'irak ça va partir
dans tous les sens cela ne collait c'est
l'album de tantale
il a objectif que c'est un truc de the
way you lie dans ces ballades de leurs
toiles à la salle est le zii en amérique
tout mon stock et on y va et va dit la
tête cachée c'est tous les albums de
cataracte n'importe quoi là mathieu les
picaros at me tenir ça va y aller
les écossais football merci mes chéris
les autres je ne demande pas j'imagine